so I have awesome news for you today it
has been the last year and a half has
been a difficult one for the David
Pakman show even though the audience has
grown significantly we've had a number
of different financial sort of
circumstances for the show starting with
YouTube ad pocalypse and some tech
issues and studio problems and yesterday
I made the big announcement that the
David Pakman show is going to be
abandoning David Pakman show studios we
are leaving at the end of our current
lease which has been almost three years
and we are going to be moving to a
state-of-the-art facility with
effectively the fastest internet
available in the Boston area short of
getting a 1 to $2,000 a month direct
fiberline or something along those lines
we are going to be increasing the
production quality of the program in
other ways and yesterday what I said was
I am NOT doing a Kickstarter campaign
I'm not doing an IndieGoGo campaign we
have basically fronted all of the costs
of doing this but what I am offering is
the opportunity to get a membership at
half price and one of two very generous
longtime contributors to the program
will pay for the other $30 memberships
normally 60 bucks and I said yesterday
that I had 200 of these discounted
memberships available I am
extraordinarily pleased to tell you that
67 of those 200 memberships are already
spoken for in just the first 24 hours I
woke up this morning to nearly 50 emails
from people saying David I want one of
those half price memberships and they
continue to trickle in during the day
and I don't know if it was the latte
language I used that resonated with
people I said if you buy one fancy latte
a month what we're talking about is that
amount of money a year to support the
program and a bunch of people emailed me
and they said David I get fancy lattes
all the time and it would be very easy
for me to just get one skip one latte a
month I want one of those half price
memberships other people said David I
don't even drink lattes and that made me
realize I'm all
ready saving 30 bucks a year because I
don't drink those lattes give me one of
those half-price memberships so let's
keep it going
67 of these half-price memberships
spoken for I am your personal membership
concierge so as I said yesterday I'm
personally handling all what hopefully
will be 200 new membership requests
people taking the opportunity not
surprisingly I guess I would say when
they email me at david at david
pakman.com or through the website
contact form to say david i want one of
those half-price memberships and here's
an interview idea or I'd love one of
those half-price memberships and here's
a story you should really look into so
I'm okay with that I am willing to let
people bend my ear a little bit in the
mission of continuing to grow and
support the David Pakman show so take it
as an opportunity to pitch a ghast or
tell me that I'm doing something right
wrong or okay or pitch a story whatever
the case may be but we have a hundred
and thirty three of these remaining
david at david pakman.com i am every
single one of you who has signed up I
have personally handled those requests
and I hope that we get 133 more and I
probably expected I don't know maybe 25
25 30 in the first 24 hours to be
requested but 67 we're off to a great
start and at some point I will really go
into the details of all of the changes
that are going to be happening which I
think are gonna be fantastic for the
program but for now I sort of laid it
out yesterday internet speed actual
sound isolated and soundproofed
production facilities which we have been
dealing with major major noise issues in
our current studio for years and it has
been to call it grating on the nerves is
probably somewhat of an understatement
so thanks to everybody get in touch 133
of the 200 memberships remain